>>
KAY: My name is Erik Kay. I want to welcome
you to this presentation. This is Developing
web apps for the Chrome Web Store. I am the
tech lead on the Chrome apps team. So before
we get started, you've seen this in other
presentations but if you want to--if you're
not--don't want to up to the mic at the end
to ask questions, feel free to use this link
to go to a wave to ask questions in the moderator
or vote up other people's question. Well,
if we don't have enough live questions we'll
go to those. Okay. So before we get going
into this, I want--I just want to have a recap
a little bit about what we talked about in
yesterday's keynote. First of, we talked about
HTML file and the amazing progress that's
been made over the last couple of years on
that front. Not just in what the capabilities
are that had been added but, you know, the
adoption by browser makers and how that's
going to progress over the next year. We also
showed how--when you take web apps and really
take advantage of all that functionality,
how truly awesome they can be that they can
be every bit as good as native applications.
And finally, we announced the Web Store where
we're trying to do our part to improve app
discovery to make it easy for developers to
monetize their web apps. And, you know, all
these together we see as all parts in trying
to build and improve the web app ecosystem.
Okay. In this talk, I'm going look at this--look
at web apps from two different perspectives.
I want to look at from the user perspective,
and for users it's all about, you know, how
can I get better web apps, you know, what's
going to make web apps as good as what I'm
used to on a desktop or on my mobile device
and how can it be easier to get them. For
developers, first and foremost, it's, look,
how do I make money doing this? And then,
you know, how do I actually build them to
start with? I really hope at the end that
you're going to come away very excited about
the possibilities about what we're doing here
because I certainly am. I think that the net
results of all these should be that end-users
are going to start getting really great web
apps and a really great experience and developers
are going to be making more money and it's
not going to be a lot of extra effort to go
it. So before we get into the meat of it,
I want to give one little caveat which is
Chromes and open source project, and that's
a blessing and a curse sometimes. The--on
the plus side, it means that you guys get
to see some of the stuff really early on.
When we check stuff into the source tree,
you know, people see what we're doing and
we have--we literally have reporters that
watch our check-ins and look for interesting
things and then report on that, so we can't
keep secrets for long. So the interesting
bit is you get to find out about stuff like
this very early on. It makes our life a little
bit trickier at times but that's as it is.
But as a result, what you're seeing here is
a technology preview, it's going to change
and not all of it all together and we don't
have all the answers. But we hope to give
you an idea of the direction and the motivations
behind what we're doing. Okay. So ground zero;
from the user's perspective, what are web
apps. Well, you know, I think everybody in
this room knows but, you know, we know it
when we see it, right? It's Gmail, it's maps,
it's mint.com, it's Pandora. Basically, it's
rich applications that are built using web
technologies designed to run in a web browser,
right? Their data tends to be stored in a
Cloud and that means it's available everywhere.
So, your home computer, your work computer,
your phone on the go; it's ubiquitous. It
doesn't matter what operating system, what
device you're using. The web is truly everywhere.
But from a user perspective, web apps can
be hard to find. You know, the first problem,
before we even get to finding them is just
knowing that they exist. Awareness is a big
deal. I mean, I'm sure, you've all had this
experience. I have myself of--you've been
using some cool web app and you show it to
a friend, you know, family member or whatever
and they go, "Oh, my god. What's that? I had
no clue that something like that even existed.
Why didn't anybody tell me?" And there's a
lot of these things that are out there that
just don't get the attention they should.
Part of this is because there are no authoritative
sources for web apps. There's no place you'd
go that shows you what are the good ones,
right? What are the ones that users use the
most, that they reviewed the best? What are
the ones that are going to help me the most?
You heard some examples in the keynote about
trying to find your, you know, a particular
game that you're interested in and how--the
fact that you can find them but you don't
know which ones are, you know, you don't see
reviews intermixed, you don't see popularity
intermixed. And, in fact, it's a little worse
than that and that you'll often see things
that are, you know, platform specific or device
specific mixed in with the web apps that are--that
you're trying to find. So on top of that,
you know, the apps themselves don't actually
do a lot to help search engines, you know,
find them. Part of this is just due to the
nature of what is an app. An app is not necessarily
content itself but it contains other content
and often the content it contains is personal,
it's private to yourself. So, that content
might not be crawlable. The web apps don't
necessarily have a lot of information to crawl
that describes what they are that helps the
search engines reinforce what's, you know,
the normal tricks that they use to find things.
So when you find an app or web app out there,
you know, most of them you'll find are free
or ad supported, but, occasionally, you'll
find some that people charge money for, and
that--they tend to have a pretty poor experience.
Part of the reason is because as a user, you
know, when you come across, you know, a web
form that says, "Okay, I want to buy something
on the web." You know, regardless of what
it is, there's an immediate question of trust.
First of, who are these guys? Now, a lot of
web apps are being built by small, unknown
companies. These are things that, you know,
people haven't heard of before, and giving
over your credit card information, your personal
information requires a certain amount of trust.
So, there's the hesitation, should I do this,
and that you'll lose some number of users
just from trust right there. The next thing
is that actually filling out your payment
information as inconvenient. It can be multiple
pages of forms just to be able to buy a really
simple thing. And the ironic thing about this
is that, the cheaper, you know, the purchase
is the more likely that those trust and inconvenience
issues actually get in the way and make it--so
you say, "Ah, I'm not going to bother. It's
just, you know, a $5 thing or a $10, it's
not worth my time." So, okay, so now you've--let's
say you get a web app. You know, we've gotten
pass some of those hard to find, hard to buy
questions, but once you'll get a web app when
there--if you look at how they interact with
browsers today, it's not ideal. Web apps sort
of by definition are special to users. These
are the things where you've got your data
in, your time in; you have--you're using it
as, you know, day-to-day stuff. It's important
to you. But the browser doesn't make it particularly
important. It treats it just like any other--any
old page. So if you look at, you know, this
browser here, you know, can you tell which
ones are the web apps, which are ones are
the ones that are important to me, you know.
Now, some of you might recognize a few of
the icons, but as you get a lot more tabs
even that becomes hard to find. You know,
further, you know, a lot of these apps, if
you compare them in to desktop apps, they're
missing a lot of functionality that you come
to expect. They don't have deep OS integration.
They don't have, you know, a shortcut to launch
it. They don't have an entry to in the taskbar
to dock. They don't have fast apps switching.
They can't open document types. They don't
have access to a lot of the underlying capabilities
that you're used to at seeing in normal desktop
apps. And they're not trusted to take--to
use that functionality. And the--part of the
reason is because of the trust model, the
security model in the Web. The nice thing
about the security model in the Web is it's
set up in such a way that you can click on
a link, any old link and not really worry
too much about it. This is different from
desktop applications where if you run any
old desktop application, you know, who knows
what's going to happen to your computer, you
know, versus with all the spyware and malware
and whatever out there. But in general, clicking
on a link at a web browser should be safe.
You should be able to trust that it does something
reasonable. But part of that trust, part of
that security model enforces limited capabilities.
And in the case where we have web apps that
we trust that we know, we want them to do
more, the web apps, the web security model
gets in the way of that. Okay. Let's see if
we can improve some things. We're going to
get a demo together here. Let's see if the
technology cooperates with us. Okay. Okay.
So you saw this in the demo yesterday. Here's
our--another take on our--on the Chrome's
new tab page. You could see, we've got this
new section at the top which is where we show
all the apps that you have installed. And
prominently, in there, right away, we have
an icon for the Web Store. So when you click
on the Web Store, it, you know, takes you
right in there and you could start browsing
apps. Now, I want to reinforce that. It's--the
Web Store is always--is one click away. We're
integrating it deeply into the browser. This
is going to be important. So you get to the
store and it has everything you would expect
it to have. It has categories, it has search,
it has reviews and ratings, it has--you could
tell which are the most popular ones, it has
promotional areas for things that, you know,
we think are interesting, and a lot of room
to do things like social recommendations or
other ways to help you discover apps. But
first and foremost, just--you can browse.
You can see what's new and interesting. And
if you see what you like and you all saw the
demo for Darkroom, the keynote I expect and
we're as impressed as I was, so I'd like to
get that now. And when I see that there, I
could hit buy in. And if you take a closer
look here, you can see what we've got is the
purchases using Google check out. Now, this
is something that if you have the account,
you should, basically, at this point only
have to type in the password to continue and
you'll get the app. Basically, this is a part
we're reducing buy in friction. Trust, it's
Google, right? So it's not somebody--some
small random company you've never heard of,
so it's easy to say, "Oh, if there's a problem
I can go to Google. I can deal with that.
They're going to take care of me." And because
it's part of this Web Store, it's not too
inconvenient to even set it up that first
time because you know there's likely going
to be more stuff and more reason to come back
for repeat purchases. So now you've got this
app and it shows up right in the launcher
and you saw it coming. And when we go ahead
and launch it, you could see that it behaves
a bit differently from a normal tab. There's
a few things to take a note of here. One is,
it created a tab on the left-hand side. It
created it as a tab with just an icon. The
icon is a bit larger than your normal fab
icon, so it's a bit easier to pick out and
see. We're automatically hiding the toolbar,
the address bar. We're giving basically more
screen real state to the app and you can get
back to that if you need to. But by default
we're trying to make the app front and center
here. Further, let's launch one or two more
here, just get those app and see, oh, we'll
put up YouTube and we'll go back and launch
TweetDeck. And you could see that each one
came in again to the left in this sort of
separate area. There's a few other features
we've got here. One is--let's say I were to
launch Darkroom again. What you'll see is
that instead of actually creating a new tab
like you would typically have with the link
that you click on, it actually refocuses the
app, iIt finds it, gives it a chance to respond
and to handle that. Again, we're trying to
treat the app more like, you know, first-class
citizen here. Also, we give the app some control
and some say over how should it launch and
how it should present itself. So, these were
all launching the tab by default but when
I launch tab Plants versus Zombies, you could
see that it jumps straight into full-screen
mode, which is exactly what you'd expect.
The game should be immersive, should take
you in, not pull you out. Now, all of these,
of course, is under user control. So, even
though an app might have a preferred, you
know, way of working, you can decide that
you want to treat things differently. Okay.
Let's pop back to... Okay. So let's talk about
money. Now, obviously, you know, that's--this
is the big question, you know, how do we make
money with web apps? As you know more people
are spending more of their time online everyday.
The Web continues to grow. This continues
to be the best reach of any platform out there
and it's only getting better. But, again,
as you k now, monetizing web apps is not always
easy. Now, probably, the easiest way today
is to use advertising, and advertising has
been great. It's really easy to set up, you
know, you just sign up for your account, drop
in a little JavaScript on your page and, you
know, start getting checks. It's pretty easy
on that front. But it may not work for everybody
and for all cases and so we want to provide
other options. So, for example, it really
works best when you have a lot of traffic,
you know, adds some volume. Advertising is
about volume. It's also has, you know, about,
you know, having low fixed costs to run your
site. That's sort of the ideal case, a small
shop with a lot of traffic. If you would say
a large new organization with a lot of foreign
bureaus, that's a huge fixed cost to overcome.
If you're a small company, you know, getting
enough traffic to even pay for your small
number of employees is a big hurdle to overcome
to attract users. You might have a lot of
marketing cost to overcome. And if for whatever
reason, you're costs are high or your traffic
is low, you don't actually get to set the
price. It is what it is. So, you can't tweak
the knobs and say, "Oh, I need to charge more
because--in order to make my business work,"
so in order to do that you really have to
charge for it. So let's look at what it takes
to actually sell your web app today. Okay.
So you can sell it but there've been a lot
of barriers to getting there. First of, it's
actually pretty--it's a lot of work. You have
to integrate with payment processors, choose
which one, choose which, you know, credit
cards you're going to accept and figure out
all the legal arrangement you needed to make
to take that, deal with a lot of issues of
like chargebacks and taxes if you need to
go international and most of you will because,
you know, the Web is global. International
is a whole another bowl of wax. You need to
have bank accounts in all the different countries
and deal with, again, all the local regulations
and rules. Now, you combine some of those,
some of that pain, some of those difficulties
with the problems I was talking about before,
you know, where there's a lot of buying friction
for users and the users can't find you to
begin with and don't even know you exist.
You're user acquisition cost wind up being
pretty high. You know, you have to, you know,
do big marketing campaigns to drop people
there. And because every user accounts and
you're, you know, trying to make it all work,
you--the common decision that's made is to
try to be as broad as you can in terms of
which browser you're going to support and
which features you're going to support. That
means that you've aimed for the least capable
browser. You don't take advantage of all the
rich features of the Web because that's, you
know, you need to reach as many users as you
can. We believe the Web Store can help cut
through a lot of these issues. So first of,
we're here to try to do as much of heavy lifting
as we can. We want to make the transaction
process as simple as we can and we want to
handle the licensing and make that really
trivial. And the thing about this is that
the Web is not a closed ecosystem. We're not--we
don't have a captive where you have no choice
but to go through us. As I said, you can sell
in the Web today. There are other options.
So we're competing against what else is out
there, so we've got to be good. We've got
to compete against that and make things smoother
for people. So how do you do this? Well, as
we've talked about, web apps are really, you
know, you know what they are. You build them
exactly as normal. Once you've got your app,
we're ready to go. You then come and sign
up for an account with the Web Store, you
know, just get your bank account set up, get,
you know, verify your demand ownership, all
that kind of stuff. And if you want to sell,
if you actually want charge for your app,
you can list free apps in the store as well,
but if you wanted to charge for your app,
add a little glue code to your backend Web
server to talk to a license server. And then
create a little bit of metadata to describe
your app, your installable web app and package
it up and upload it to our server and then
you'll be ready to go. So I just described
it, I was--but I'll show you a quick walk
through of what it looks like today. Now,
for those of you who have built Chrome extension,
this is all going to look really familiar
to you and that's not an accident. The Web
Store is actually built on the same technology
that we use for--for the extension gallery,
and in fact, the extension gallery will turn
in to the Web Store. What this means is that
you're going to be able to sell themes and
extensions as well as web apps. But for those
of you who haven't seen this, basically, you
have your little zip file of metadata; you
upload it, you get to a little page that sort
of shows you what you're layout is going to
look like. You set some--your icons, some
descriptions, you pick a category, you upload
some screenshots, maybe a link to a YouTube
video, then you say publish and then it's
live. Now, we're talking, you know, minutes,
not days, weeks, months. In most cases our
aim--and this is true with the extension gallery
today. In most cases our aim is for approval
to be automatic. There'll be--we obviously
have legal requirements and issues and, you
know, policies that--where we have to like,
you know, potentially take things down to
the local laws and whatnot. But in general,
things will get up and published without direct
manual intervention. So Chrome users as you
saw in the keynote the other day have been
growing pretty fast. We're over 70 million
active users and it's continuing to grow.
Now, Chrome is integrated with the Web Store
right on the main page. As you have heard
with our auto-update mechanism makes it so
that people are all pretty much running the
latest versions of Chrome very quickly. As
we get things--these things out, everyone's
got the latest stuff. So when the stable channel
goes--push goes out it has all of this stuff
some time later this fall. You know, everybody
will have that Web Store icon in their browser
and we'll have a lot more users than that
at this point. So that's a lot of users for
guiding straight into the store. So this is
lower purchase friction, this is easy to find,
easy to buy. Google is going to be putting
a fair amount of marketing effort into the
store. We're going to be helping to promote
your apps. All of this is going to translate
into a net lower cost of user acquisition
for you. Now, on top of that, Chrome as you
know has all the latest HTML5 features in
it that you want. New stuff coming down the
road like WebGL, existing stuff like all of
the great, you know, CSS transitions. I think
what I'm trying to get at here is that this
is a lot of users and it's growing and you
don't have to target the least capable browsers
anymore. You can take advantage of the best
features and make your apps awesome and you
can make money doing that. This is all part
of the web app ecosystem, right, and it starts
with you, the developer. I hope we're convincing
you that it's worthwhile to really step back
and build your, you know, cool new HTML5 application.
It's really easy, say, you put it out in the
store and as you know all the users are going
to--all those Chrome users are going to be
coming to the store and some of them are going
to find your app, love your app, give it great
reviews and give you some money in exchange
for the app. And as we know money for developer
makes a happy developer. And hopefully convinces
you to make more apps or make your apps even
better and, you know, we're adding more users
all the time but more apps, you know, are
going to even draw even more users and, of
course, more love and more money. I think
you got the idea. This is all a virtuous circle.
It increases competition, increases app quality,
increases user happiness, you know, and all
around. So I didn't go into too much detail
yet. Let's dive into a little bit of the knots
and bolts of what goes into your actual app.
Now, any web app can go in the Web Store today.
If it runs in Chrome, you know, built--just
using normal HTML5, Flash, whatever, you could
package it up and put it in the store. However,
we think you should do more than that, right?
We think you should be trying to take advantage
of--with a great new features of HTML5 and
CSS3 and all the other amazing features that
are out there; there's a lot of them. And
you--if you haven't gotten to see the HTML5
talk that happened yesterday, I encourage
you to check out the video. There's another
talk later today that's going to talk about
some of the features. I think there's a session
going on right after this at the Chrome Hack
Alcove where you can walk through some of
the cool HTML5 stuff that you can do. If you
haven't played around with this stuff, definitely
dive in and see what you can do. You saw some
of the apps in the keynote but I think we're
really just scratching the surface of the
level of polish and performance. I'd like
you to, though, not think of this, it's just
a feature checklist, right? This isn't just
a, "Oh, I should add this feature. I should
add that feature." We need to step back as
Web developers and think more like, you know,
the way desktop app developers think. It's
about polish, it's about performance, it's
about all these little niceties that make
it feel rock solid. How can we make these
great apps, deal with offline, maintaining
state, you know, make it fast, you know, Chrome
team are very passionate about speed and we
hope to pass on some of that passion to you
as well. We really need to set a higher bar
for the quality and features set at these
apps and if you don't other people well and
competition will be fierce there. So once
you've made your app, we now want to make
it an installable app, an installable web
app. So, to do that, we create a little bit
of metadata and that gets packaged up using
the Chrome extension system. You don't have
to worry about that, we do that all for you
on the Web Store. If you want to sell your
app, you do a little bit of glue to integrate
with the license server. So--and then you're
ready to go. Now, so let's actually show this
in action. Okay. So I've got a little app
here that you probably heard of before. Let's
see. So--let's increase the font size here.
Hopefully, it's good enough for you to see.
This is just a little bit of JSON. It's very
simple. There's not a lot to it. We have a
name. We have a version. We have a list of
icons. We have a launch URL. And that's really
about it. That's the meta--all the metadata
we need to describe it. You also saw that
we had a set of icons that came with it that
helps us, you know, display it in all the
different formats. So in order to develop
that against this, as I said, the technology
here is built on the Chrome extension system.
It's kind of an implementation detail. I wouldn't
get to hang up on it right now. All these
is--oops, check point. All of this is in progress
and probably will change to get a little more
app specific. But for now we're demoing it
using this--the extension system. So to do
that what you do is you just load the directory
to load the metadata in and this will behave
just like you bought the web app from the
store and you could see we now have our Google
Maps app sitting there ready to go. And we
launch it and it has the app tab and its nice
icon and it's there and it behaves just like
the app we got from the store. And really
that was it. It just that little bit of JSON,
that extra icon and that was all to define
it. Now, what about richer capabilities, some
of the additional features that we might want
to add. Well, one thing to--I don't know if
everybody is aware of but actually Google
Maps had a geolocation support not long ago.
And there's this little icon here on geolocation
enabled browsers that if you click on will
cause you to jump to your current location.
But you can see here that actually what it
did is it put up a little info bar on top
that says that maps.google.com wants to, you
know, look at your location, is that okay.
And the user has to opt in, it has to say,
"Yes, I trust the site to do this." So that's
great. This is--again, back to the trust model,
the security model of the web. We don't want
any old brand and page to be able to see my
physical location without me saying it's okay
for that to happen. But I've installed this
app, you know, I've kind of given my signal
that I trust it. And the gallery will tell
me what--upfront what the app can do and users
have reviewed it and helps me out to know
that this is a trustworthy thing. So, I want
to let it do this implicitly. Now, if we--let's
see. Let me show you sort of a worst case
thing that can happen here. With geolocation
maybe it was all right. For--it might have
been all right to say, you know--let me ask,
you know, I understand geolocation. Geolocation
makes sense, but what about if I want to use
a few more features? If I want to make a rich
app that really took advantage of everything?
Well, you could see, it can get pretty crazy,
you know, prompting user for every single
little thing that it wants to do could get
out of hand. And there are a lot of rich capabilities
coming to HTML and the web. And a lot of this
is being driven by a handset--the phone makers.
Some of it, it's going to be driven by what's
happening in Chrome OS and basically our desire
to make web apps more capable. Things like,
you know, access to your webcam, you know.
Again, you wouldn't want ran in webpage to
do that without you getting into it. But,
some of these features are actually, some
of the things we want to add don't necessarily
make sense, they even ask you. Don't necessarily
make sense to prompt sometimes because they
really trivial things; sometimes because they're
very hard to explain. Imagine say for example
a website wanted to see check your idle state.
They want to see like whether you're away
from your, stepped away from your computer.
This could be really useful if you want to
make a web-based instant messaging client
for example. But, that could be privacy invading
but that's kind of a hard thing to explain
in a little, you know, info bar, a little
dialog. So, you know, you could imagine your
average user getting something that says,
"Hey, this website wants to get access to
your idle time, you know, is that okay?" Say,
"Well, I don't know, whatever, maybe." And,
or what if they want to access your pasteboard,
that seems safe. Well, there's some security
ramifications to that but, it's, again, something
might not want to try to explain. So there's
a lot of these things coming and we want to
make the trust model simpler. So let's go
back and see how we could do that. Let's see.
All right. So we have our geolocation app
here, oops. Let's see. Sorry. All right. Let's
open up our manifest again, and what we're
going to do is add one additional field here.
Again this would be familiar to people who
played around with extension system. We're
going to add a geolocation permission. So
this is basically saying declaring upfront
that I want my app to be able to use the geolocation
functionality. So this way we could expose
in the gallery to people knowing that this
app uses this feature. And then what I want
to debug this to try it out again. Just reload
it, launch it. And this time when I click
on the geolocation thing you could see a jumps
right to my location without prompting me.
So, we think this is, this model of, sort
of, having a user to be able to trust in app
and say, yes, this app is something that I
like and that I use and I want to be more
capable is much more intuitive. If you've,
you know, thought it all about security you
know that asking users to answer complex security
questions isn't good security. It's also not
good UI and asking users a lot of security
questions is even worse on both of those fronts.
So our hope is that this simplifies this yet
keeps the security model intact. By the way,
the other to note is that it also simplifies
the removing of these permissions, removing
this capabilities because if you think about
20 different types of features that you might
have granted to any old website, what's the
user interface for that look like. We'll there's
going to be some options panels somewhere
in an advance setting that says, here's a
list of all of the sites that have access
to geolocation. I want to block this site
and deny this site or something. Or here's
all the sites that I've ever granted any permission
to at all and now I need to browse each one
and individually select it. In this model,
you just uninstall the app. It's, all the
permissions are gone, you don't have to think
about what did you grant, what didn't you
grant, is just all taken care of in one, one
fell swoop. Okay. I'm sorry, one second. Technology,
it's great. Okay. So let's recap a little
bit. So from a user's perspective, we're talking
about getting great apps, you know, that they're
easy to find that they're more capable. From
a developer's perspective, it's easy to build.
We're already doing it. We can, it's easy
to make money, it's easy to sell. There's
lower cost of users. You know, basically,
the net effect should be, you know, we've
got more options basically. You know, you
can keep doing things the way you do but,
now things are more discoverable to users.
You can take advantage of the latest features
and not worry that you're not reaching enough
users. So, okay, this is a meeting and nobody
likes getting action items in meetings but,
I'm going to give you, guys, a few. So, the
first thing you should do is you have already
is go check out the FAQ that we've setup.
This, try to answer some of the, you know,
obvious questions about how this is all going
to work and what's going to, what's happening
there. This is also by the way the location
of the stores actually going to show up at
when it goes live. Check out the technical
documentation, just see what's there. There's
not a lot to it. As you saw it's very simple
so, what's up there today is very minimum
and also as I told you before, this is early
on, so it's going to change, but keep an eye
on that. And then, go build a really cool
app. Now, you know, or, convert your existing
app to, you know, use, you know, the cool
HTML5 features you've seen at Google I/O here.
Basically, the clock is sort of ticking on
the store now and I think this is a good opportunity
to get in early. We're going to have a developer
preview where you're going to build, upload
stuff and play with the store sometime later
this summer. And, in fall, it's going to be
opened up for consumers. So, this is all going
to come pretty quickly, I'll be here before
you know it. And so, if you don't start on
your app now, you know, you'll miss the initial
watch on that front. And join the discussions.
Now, on the docs in FAQ sites, we've got some
links to some mailing list and but there's
already plenty chromium, you know, just general
mailing list. We love getting community involvement.
As an open source project, we have a lot of
external contributors. We have IRC channels,
all of our sources have checked in, the public,
so you could all check all of this stuff out
and get involved personally. If you want to
influence the direction that we're headed,
if you want to change some of the things have
you think we're making some stupid decisions
here and there, we love to hear it. And, you
know, it's not just about the web app and
the web store stuff, it's about anything like,
you know, if you're not convinced that HTML5
has everything you need today, let us know
about that too. We want to know what it takes
to make, what you need to make your apps as
good as or better than desktop, mobile, you
know, native equivalence. So, once again,
I think we've got a little time for questions.
So if you want to ask live questions to the
mic, that's fine. Or we'll, we could check
out the wave as well if you don't have enough
live questions. Sure.
>> So, yeah, thanks for the presentation.
It's very interesting. So, there's another
company that has a slogan, there's an app
for that. And, well, my question is the technology
is really interesting but I'm not still convinced
that people are going to Chrome and try to
buy apps. So can you talk a little bit about
what marketing initiatives are going to be
made available for, like, obviously, you know,
this other company they push marketing out
there that push people to go to the App Store.
>> KAY: Sure.
>> What is Google going to do to like promote
apps and to make it, you know, because I still
use Firefox as my primary browser and so,
if I'm not way, I'm a developer, I feel like,
skepticism that people are actually going
to Chrome and want to buy stuff and know that
it's even there?
>> KAY: Sure, sure. Well, I appreciate that.
Yeah, if it's too early to talk about some
any detail, probably the specifics of our
marketing initiatives is probably the one
that we're at least equipped to go into the
specifics about right now unfortunately. But,
I think the big take home point is that this
is an important initiative for us. It's something
that we take very seriously and you hit on
another issue which is just Chrome adoption
in general. And this is also something that,
you know, Google is very committed to and
we are spending, you know, a lot of effort
not just on marketing but just on, you know,
putting our money where our mouth is quality
wise. We're continuing to up to bar performance
wise, quality wise with the browser and we
think that, you know, on that front action,
action speaks louder than words. But, yeah,
we definitely want to drive more users, you
know, in the Chrome, into the web store. The
other thing is that, you know, these apps,
I tried to make this clear before but, this
is a question where we keep getting from people
is, you know, will these apps run in another
browsers, and the answer is absolutely yes.
Step one, start with the web app. And we're
encouraging to make a modern web app so maybe
you'll only run modern web browsers, you know,
the latest Firefox, Safari, you know, Opera,
Chrome; but these apps should run in another
browsers. All we've done is put patch up some
metadata to make it an installable web app
that makes it a little bit better experience,
a little bit more integrated and with the
browser, that doesn't change the core functionality
of the app, the app will still work. Likewise,
if you buy the app, you know, that app should
still work, you know, in another browsers.
>> Are the apps are going to be able to be
synchronized between my browser or in my Chrome
in Linux or my Chrome in Windows on different
computers?
>> KAY: Yeah, absolutely. I missed that earlier.
I meant to say that the--when you buy an app,
it's tied to your account and we synch just
like other things are synched with synchronization
features that are built into Chrome.
>> Just, another question, are we going to
be able to sell extensions as well as apps?
>> KAY: Yes, extensions and themes as well
as apps.
>> So, that telling with that other browsers
that offer extensions since it's open source
and open, are you guys going to or have thought
about allowing extensions from other browsers
to be sold within this store?
>> KAY: It's a good question and I'll just
be honest and say, we haven't talked about
it. I don't know if there's any particular
version to it. But, since we haven't talked
about it, I'd just be speculating right now
about what we decide.
>> Okay. And just let's assume that it's the
case like, you know, goading on this. Would
you guys allow Potomac API that would allow
the importing of like a massive number of
extensions?
>> KAY: We've actually had that question before
and you know I think, it would have to be
sort of one off kind of thing. You know, not,
it's not something we want to look at on a
general basis probably just because, you know,
the potential, we want them at the potential
for spam and for other sort of things. But,
you know, I think we'd open to, assume, especially
assuming we're willing to like, you know,
look at other extensions systems than, yeah,
it make sense to consider that.
>> Okay, cool.
>> Yeah, two questions for you. Is there any
plans to include gadgets in the store at all?
>> KAY: What do you mean by gadgets?
>> iGoogle gadgets.
>> KAY: Oh, not at this time. Again, it's
mostly that right now, I guess, I shouldn't
answer that way. I should say, we haven't
talked about it. So I'm on the Chrome team
and we've been focused on the things for Chrome
in particular and we just haven't tried with
the iGoogle folks about that. But, there's
certainly the opportunity once we have the
infrastructure in place to consider selling
other things like, you know, other extensions
or iGoogle gadgets or, you know, whatever
else. But, right now, we're focused on apps
extension themes for Chrome.
>> Okay. And certainly my question, is in
the billing model that you're releasing, will
it support variable recurring, recurring based
upon usage as an example.
>> KAY: So, we definitely think that lots
of billing mechanisms are going to be critical
and important for the web. Subscription systems
and app payment, you know, group, bulk purchases,
these are all things we want to do. At this
time, I don't know if we have timelines for
exactly what's going to rule out when, which
functionality is going to be there.
>> But in your first release, will there be
a form or recurring?
>> KAY: Like I said, at this point, we don't
know from a timeline perspective, from a rule
out perspective, which payment options are
going to be end yet. So, we'll, you know,
try to get that information out as quickly
as we can but we're still working through
it.
>> Okay. Thanks.
>> KAY: Uh-hmm.
>> So, hopefully, you'll be available at office
hours because I have a number of questions
but...
>> KAY: Sure. There are office hours for Chrome,
just upstairs. Actually, they've already started
now, so it's from now until, I don't know,
four or something.
>> Awesome. But the one question then I think
could actually be more valuable for like an
audience maybe here is in handling issues
regarding transitions into the store front.
Say for instance some already have a webpage.
Man, as you said, the one of the big features
of this is that you're existing site is an
essence, an application. And a lot of users
are going to, want to be able to utilize the
functionality such as the little icons in
the upper left and the easy extension, sorry,
the easy capability automatic allowing, et
cetera. But if the users already been using
our site and is already paid for it, in essence,
because we've been using existing payment
models. Is there going to be some mechanism
by which we can tell you this list of Google
account should be authorized to apps that
people don't feel almost like, oh, I should
have waited that extra month to get the app
once it hit the Chrome stores because now
I'm never going to get that icon.
>> KAY: Sure, sure. I could totally see the
use-case you're talking about. That's a great
idea, it's a great suggestion and we, that's
kind of a feedback we're looking for. So I
think the best thing I could suggest on that
front is to get involved in the mailing list,
the discussion so toss it out there, or even
file a bug directly, we'll, and because, you
know, that's the kind of feedback that's going
to help us really make this great and, you
know, by launch time.
>> All right, thank you.
>> KAY: Uh-hmm.
>> I was just wondering if you could speak
to the experience that the user will have
when they're downloading the app and then
I guess it would be like Android, you say
to them, hey, we want to know your location,
we'd like to store offline data and then they
click that one time what you did basically
to bypass that. Is it going to be like the
Android phone or perhaps you could just describe
that experience.
>> KAY: Sure. So, we actually want the security--well...
>> Okay.
>> KAY: There's two answers to that, so one
is you can look at how the extension systems
works today if you've installed the Chrome
extension. And in some ways, yeah, it does
behave similarly to the Android model where
there's a set of capabilities that it takes
advantage of and it says those upfront at
install time. However, we actually think that
in many ways, the permissions that we're talking
about for web apps are inherently a bit more
safe than the extension system. And so we
want to make it an even lighter weight system
for granting those permissions. So, the permissions
will likely be, you know, part of gallery
of listing page prominently displayed, but
aren't necessarily going to be part of the
direct install flow. As you saw right there
it was, essentially, aside from confirming
the account, it was really a one click thing
to get it in there and we didn't, don't want
to really interrupt that unless it's really
necessary. So if there's higher and security
features are permission that they need then
we'll start looking back at it. But, for now,
the ones that we're looking at, I think, are,
can be handled by the gallery by itself.
>> The payment question. Do you have any plans
to allow alternative billing relationships
between a developer and a consumer, or do
you have plans to make the checkout manager?
>> KAY: Right, that's a great question. And,
I, unfortunately, I can't give you a good
answer on that right now. A lot of the--I
know this could be, this is kind of a frustrating
non-answer but, a lot of the details about
the payment mechanisms and the legal agreements
and the contracts and all that stuff are,
we're too really on to get commitments. We
definitely have ideas and, you know, but,
how we wanted to go but until we get them
a little further along, it's probably not
a good idea to, you know, share have finished
ideas. And, so, we're going to try our best
to get you the answers as quickly as we can
but, you know, keep an eye out for that.
>> All right. For, you know, mobile apps there's,
you know, everybody knows go to an apps store
App Store or a market to go get the apps.
But, for a browser, you know, for Chrome App
Store apps or which are accessible otherwise
also. So, how do you ensure like, you know,
people get directed to the Chrome App Store
for that? Or like what could happen if I directly
go the website instead of discovering through
the Chrome store.
>> KAY: Sure.
>> And then, how will the purchasing experience
then extend to other browsers? You know that's
one detail we're also missing.
>> KAY: Sure. So, I'll take the first one,
first part first. I think to some degree how
your app behaves when a user comes in who
hasn't necessarily bought the app yet is kind
of, is going to be up to the app developer
to figure out exactly what they want. We're
definitely going to have a way to link back
in until like say, okay, you're now in the
app and we want to have you be able to complete
the transaction. Say I have tried the app
but I like it now I want to buy it and have
that full through into the store, but how
that's going work exactly? We're not ready
to go into details yet. The second part of
our purchasing in another browsers; I think
that we're definitely open to that that idea.
And but I can't speak for the other browsers.
Some of it involves just the stuff that they
would need to implement in their browsers
and we'd certainly want to encourage that
and want to work with them to like help make
that happen. But, we're in, just starting
our discussions with them about, you know,
how this is all going to work and what the
format should exactly look like and if they're
even on board with the idea and the whole.
So, until we have more to share on that, you
know, it has to come from, would love to hear
what they say, I guess, is the short answer
for that.
>> Can you speak about the, about integrating
with Google App Engine which you have to do
with licensing server.
>> KAY: Sure. So, you're talking about the
enterprise apps marketplace?
>> Yeah, you mentioned there had to be some
Glue in the backend.
>> KAY: Yeah, it's a good question. So, the
enterprise apps marketplace is definitely
serving sort of a different need, a different
goal. The, you know, it's more about, you
know, organizations who are using apps for
your domain. You know, I want integration
with Google Apps. And, we're on the flipside
trying to aim more at consumers, you know,
finding...
>> Oh, sorry, I'm not talking about the enterprise,
I'm talking about Google App Engine, so if
I want to make an app for just regular users
not in an enterprise domain.
>> KAY: Oh, so, but, yeah, having the App
Engine integrate with the license server,
we want to make that as easy as we can, and
for sure. And, you can pretty much rest assure
that there's going to be sample code and stuff
built-in. I mean, ideally, we'd love to make
it even just sort of a one click thing of
like package up my app and have a wizard that
gives you like here, okay, you're missing
this icon and here's your, which URL do you
want to start at and what, you know, and have
it all be a one stop thing where you can just
configure it and go. But, again, that's wishlist
and I can't say timing wise when that's going
to exactly happen. But, there, certainly will
be sample code out there that will be easy
to integrate into App Engine.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> So, I have two questions. The first one
is the, if you're making a device that has
device value that doesn't meet the standards
yet. Would you, say that it's a better approach
to try and put native client? And do web apps
that integrate with native client or to put
Android on to that device and use the JavaScript
interface and do web apps and Android that
will let you and then you build your native
capabilities as data are stored?
>> KAY: I'm sorry. I didn't fully follow what
you were...
>> So there seem to be two different approaches
here, the web, the Chrome approach. You put
Chrome and native client on to the device...
>> KAY: Okay.
>> ...and get native capabilities in to web
apps that way or to put Android onto a device
and use Android, the web view package in Android
has add JavaScript interface which lets you
basically transmit and tend some activities...
>> KAY: Uh-ha.
>> ...from Java domain into JavaScript and
that...
>> KAY: Sure. Well, I mean, I'll just caveat
this by saying that I'm not an Android developer
so, I don't know necessarily all that much
about what they're doing. But, what we're
talking about is, you know, primarily web
applications, right? And so these are things
that, if they run in Chrome, you know, then
we can, you know, well, you can list them
on the store and sell them that way. Now,
there are advantages to building native apps,
right, on the device. And if you're aiming
at, you know, a mobile phone, you know, a
particular, an Android, maybe you want to
build an Android app. I guess, it depends
on your goal. If you're trying to hit a wide
variety of devices, something which will run,
you know, on different OSs and different browsers.
Take advantage of, you know, larger screens
and desktops and whatever then, you know,
Chrome and Chrome apps, web, I mean, web apps
for Chrome, you know, that's going to be more
what you want. So, I guess, it's hard to answer
your answer because it's so apps specific
about what it is that you need, what your
capabilities are.
>> So the goal, the goal is probably to build
the most future proof platform for...
>> KAY: Sure.
>> ...delivering applications across the heterogeneous
ecosystem.
>> KAY: Sure. Well, I've got my own opinions
about what that would be and, but, I'm sure
the Android people would have like their own
opinions as well.
>> Maybe we should talk about this in the
Sandbox because my next question was about
security models for native client integrated
into...
>> KAY: Sure.
>> ...and that, again...
>> KAY: Okay, yeah, we could talk afterwards.
>> Hi, hello.
>> KAY: Yup.
>> Do you have applications in .net that are
enterprise? And we're thinking about making
a small basic version of that for the, using
the Google platform, and we want to give it
at the same looking field. How do you suggest
we go about doing that?
>> KAY: Well, without seeing your app it's,
okay, basically, the question was I've got
a native app and, you know, .net app and how
do I make it as polished as, you know, using
the web? And, without seeing your app, you
know, I can't give specific advice.
>> It's actually in a, it's a web based app
in .net.
>> KAY: Oh, okay. So, when you say a web based
app in .net, you mean, the server side is
.net or...?
>> Yeah, on the server side is .net.
>> KAY: Sure. Well, with--so, the server side
shouldn't impact the client look and fell.
You should be able to use all of the CSS,
you know, all of the HTML5 tags you need from
ASP.NET. So, I would say just, you know, take
a look into some of the latest CSS standards,
from the latest HTML5 stuff. There's a really
organized online book, Dive Into HTML5, for
example, as a good primer on some of the basics
there. There are a lot of great tutorials
out there by using the video tag and using--it
depends on your app. But, there's, I'd also
recommend to go check out the presentation
that I mentioned earlier, that happened yesterday
about there's an HTML5 presentation that sort
of, that actually shows it from this perspective
of how do I make an apps that's really great,
it looks really polished that looks like a
native app, and has a lot of the cool features.
And, so there's could video that posted if
you missed it, so.
>> Can we also interface with our database
using the Google Chrome web store?
>> KAY: I'm not sure what you mean by your
database.
>> We have a database already in SQL for the
enterprise app, can we link when we make the
Google...
>> KAY: So the web app doesn't change. Your,
if your web app talks to database, it's the
same web app. So, it's just a little bit of
extra Glue to make it an installable web app,
but the web app itself if exactly the same.
So if it can talk to the database today, that's
fine. And as an enterprise app, you know,
it means that, you know, when the user downloads
it presumably there's some, you know, configuration
that's going to be needed--maybe we should
talk offline about that, okay.
>> Okay, thanks.
>> KAY: Yup.
>> Hi, I got two questions; the first one
is going to be the easy one. Are you guys
are going to take a cut of the purchases to
the web store?
>> KAY: So, basically, I think the answer
to that right now is we're going to be very
similar to what you're seeing in another web
store, another app stores out there. I'm hesitating
this because we don't have specific numbers
to share right now but, you can expect similar
arrangement to what's coming out there.
>> Okay. So, second a little bit complicated.
Is there a DRM model? If so, is it client,
web apps encrypted client side or is it server
side so you do that somewhere around. So I'm,
basically, you know, could someone just copy
the web app and essentially, really what do
you are selling? Are you just selling basically
the traffic like...?
>> KAY: Sure. So, DRM is on the server side.
So basically the licensing--your web app will
talk to our licensed server to verify that
this user has, in fact, you know, bought the
app and so that that you know that. I think
that, you know, for pure like, it's possible
the package-up things are purely offline like
extensions for example. And for those, you
know, the, any kind of protection we put in,
is likely to be along the lines of keeping
honest people honest as opposed to like some
massively complicated, you know, DRM system.
Our general take especially as an open source
project is that, you know, complicated DRM
doesn't work. And that, you know, people who
want to bypass it, can bypass it. So, the
idea is if you do anything on that front is
to make is so it's a simple hurdle so that
people know that they are copying against
your intentions. And that as long as that's
the case, then the people who are going to
bypass it anyway, will do so. The people who
say, oh, I didn't realize what...
>> Yeah, I get that so on the server side,
we're going have some kind of server to hit,
to authenticate the client...
>> KAY: That's right.
>> ...for using it and that, would that be
tied to the browser or to an account or unique
ID or...>
>> KAY: Basically, it'd be tied to a user
ID of some kind. So, well, the license server,
we don't have a lot of details to share right
now but it's going to be based on, you know,
open standards. Things like OAuth and OpenID,
so there would be some user token behind that.
>> All right. Thank you.
>> KAY: Uh-hmm. All right. It looks like we're
out of time here anyway. So, no more questions?
But thank you all for coming.